have you ever had hair colors at a panel
yeah one time really yeah they were
what hasn't so oh got it was it a
[ __ ]
hentai panel and oh well that's of
course of course
dude r18 panels i've never done one
because it's
everything i've heard about is a [ __ ]
horse oh my god i call if i didn't
mention this in like the convention
story yeah so i do
i i offer to like conventions i'm like
hey do you want me to run a hentai
dubbing panel yeah
um and essentially what it is is i just
get a bunch of hentai and i blow out the
subtitles
and i'm like wing it right just just
make [ __ ] up
yeah yeah people are [ __ ] terrible at
it yeah yeah and that's what's funny
but eventually you'll get like one
person who's actually like really
[ __ ] funny right yeah and that's what
it's for yeah but
i one time i was doing it and there's
this dude in the back he must have been
like
30 something just on his own and he was
just shouting cringe
cringe cringe the whole time and i was
like do you want to come up
he was like no and i'm like well get the
[ __ ] out then and everyone was like
golf clubs and then they clapped
everyone no
no because our panels there's always
that one guy who thinks
that like the panel was a youtube
comment section yeah
and and they always try to like be that
[ __ ] smart ass
and like throw out that smart ass
comment and it never [ __ ] it's never
[ __ ] funny you know who you are
i don't know i must be blessed because
i've never had that in a panel of mine
i mean normally at this type of panel
the people loud people are good because
you could just bring them up
yeah yeah i mean if if i ever put into
that situation i'd do exactly the same
thing right
god it was terrible stolen the [ __ ] off
one time there was this hentai and it
was
brother and sister right and a brother
and sister came up to dub it
and it was the most the first thing i'd
ever done in my life
oh god it was terrible yeah that's
cursed it was so cursed
i regretted it and it you know when you
do something you're like this sounds
hilarious and then it starts you're like
oh no
oh no please stop please stop this it's
just like immediate regret yeah
i mean they offered and i was like oh
god yeah this sounds funny and
no no no no no no i've never been
tempted to do
an r18 panel no i've i've only seen like
bad things happening i've only seen and
heard the worst thing because here's the
thing like if you come to my panel
like i'm usually open to any kind of
[ __ ] question it is yeah but it seems
like when people see r18 in a panel
because i've been i've been to r18
panels yeah they they asked [ __ ] that
is not like it's it's bad
i mean it's not a question it's just
doubt hentai don't [ __ ] do anything
weird
yeah and if you do no but what i'm
talking about is like the r18 like q a
power yeah those are [ __ ] weird i
don't get those like i don't know what
it is some people just think oh it's r18
therefore i can ask them the most like
private [ __ ] yeah
that they otherwise wouldn't say i'm
like no [ __ ] i'm not gonna tell
you private [ __ ] just because it's r18
i don't care like [ __ ] even my
therapist doesn't ask things yeah here
you are
just asking about the most intimate
[ __ ] details of my life
you know what i mean i've never been on
another 18 panel but i've seen some of
the questions that has
some of the questions that have been
asked on our 18 panels it's horrible
it's horrible
it just depends on the crowd doesn't it
really sometimes you get real like oh
god and sometimes they're quite funny
that's the thing it can be funny but
there are just some people who don't
know what funny is like it's funny to
them but then the moment it comes out
everyone's like
yikes you shouldn't have said that